SPEAKER: Imagine if you could
rush through a McDonald's
drive-through, or pick
up a dog at the ballpark
without fumbling
for your wallet.
Welcome to Hands Free Payments,
a quick and convenient way
to pay for things
in-store by just
saying, "I'll pay with Google."
Hands Free is currently
supported at select locations,
including McDonald's,
Papa John's,
and numerous other merchants.
This video will show you,
as a merchant or a merchant
developer, how you
can enable Hands Free
payments through your
point of sale system.
But first, here's
a quick overview
of how the Hands Free
user experience works.
As a customer, you simply
download Hands Free
onto your Android or iOS phone.
When you run the app
for the first time,
you'll add your photo,
your name, and credit card
information.
And after that,
you're ready to go.
You don't even need to pull out
the phone to make a payment.
Hands Free uses Bluetooth
Low Energy, Wi-Fi,
and Location
Services on the phone
to detect when you're in a
store that accepts Hands Free.
When you're ready to pay,
simply tell the cashier,
"I'll pay with Google."
The cashier will then press
the Google tender button.
Hands Free automatically
verifies your identity
and shows your photo on the POS.
It does so by using a
Hands Free in-store camera
and visual identification
technology.
In some cases, if Hands Free
cannot find you right away,
the cashier also has the option
of searching for your initials
to pull up your photo.
Hands Free does not pass
your full payment information
to the store or the POS.
Instead, once you're
identified, Google
interfaces with the merchant's
preferred payment processor
to complete the charge.
Once the charge
completes, you'll
get a notification in the
Hands Free app as confirmation.
As a merchant, here's
how you get all this up
and running in your store,
so that you can start
accepting Hands Free payments.
Your Google representative
will work with you
to ensure that your store's
hardware is set up properly
to support Hands Free customers.
This includes ensuring
that your POS is connected
to the Internet,
since it'll need
to talk to the Hands Free
API to query and find
the right customer to charge.
The Hands Free API
exposes a number of calls,
but they can be separated
into two groups.
One is for looking
up nearby customers.
And the other is for performing
transactions on a customer
once you've identified
the correct person.
The first step is
looking up a customer.
When the customer says,
"I'll pay with Google,"
the cashier presses a Google
tender button on the POS.
The POS then calls
the consumer query
API to query for
nearby customers that
are found using
the in-store camera
for visual identification.
Here's an example of what your
query request might look like
and the response you'd get back.
We would return to you
the customer's first name,
a URL that points to a
photo of the customer,
and a SessionToken that you
can use in subsequent API
calls to perform
transactions on the customer.
Once you have all
of this information,
you'll need to make
the POS display
those customers to the cashier.
Now, if no customers
are found, the POS
needs to display a
prompt to the cashier
to enter the
customer's initials.
The initials provide
the Hands Free
system with a bit more data
to pinpoint nearby customers.
After the cashier enters
the customer's initials,
the POS should call the
consumer query API again,
this time including
those initials.
In most cases, the
consumer query call
will return a single customer.
But it is possible that
more than one customer
will be returned.
In this case, the POS needs to
display all of the customers
it finds, so that
the cashier can
select the correct customer who
is standing in front of them.
As I mentioned, each customer
has a unique SessionToken.
And you can use that
SessionToken to perform charges
and refunds on that customer.
To charge a
customer, you'll need
to use a transaction
charge API call.
Here's an example of what your
charge request might look like.
The call is pretty simple.
All you need to do
is pass parameters,
such as a request ID,
the charge amount,
the customer's SessionToken,
and optional line item data,
so that we can show the
customer a digital receipt.
And the response will
return to you whether or not
the charge was
successful, as well as
details, such as the charge
amount and the payment
instrument that was used.
On the POS, you'll need to
create a Hands Free transaction
confirmation screen, or just
leverage an existing screen
to show the cashier the
transaction confirmation.
Occasionally, some charges
require user confirmation.
This happens when a risk engine
detects a transaction that
appears suspicious.
And there are API calls
to handle these scenarios.
There are additional API
calls for performing refunds
and canceling transactions too.
And these are outlined in
our full API documentation.
This has just been a high
level overview of the API.
So if you're interested in
setting up Hands Free payments,
please reach out to us.
A Google representative
can help get
you set up with
your own account,
access to the full API
documentation, and even
a reference implementation
and sample code
to get you ramped up quickly.
If you want to learn more,
please reach out to us
at handsfree@google.com.
For now, keep on
paying with Google.
And thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]